à françois guillaume chevrollier merci
monsieur le président la question
s'adresse au ministre de l'agriculture
monsieur le ministre la colère gronde
chez les agriculteurs dans tout l'ouest
de la france
mon département la mayenne territoires à
fort potentiel agricole pas réponse s'il
vous plaît allez bien évidemment
concerné monsieur le ministre je vous
avais déjà alerté à plusieurs reprises
sur le ras-le-bol de nos agriculteurs de
nos éleveurs comment en effet supporter
de travailler durement sans toucher des
revenus décents sans pouvoir offrir à sa
famille un niveau de vie satisfaisant et
sans avoir aucune perspective
encourageante
que dire à nos jeunes agriculteurs
monsieur ministre aujourd'hui vous nous
proposer un plan d'urgence de 24 mesures
mais pourquoi avoir tant attendu
qu'avez vous fait pour l'organisation
des filières depuis trois ans
aujourd'hui la situation est tendue
la révolte est grande chez les éleveurs
qu'ils soient bovins porcins laitiers
ils ne se contenteront pas de vos
rustine ni de vos grands principes
comment voulez vous qu'ils soient
rassurés par votre proposition numéro 22
qui promet une amélioration des
relations contractuelles dans les
filières animales
l'intention est bonne mais nos
agriculteurs veulent du concret et des
solutions pérennes les aides immédiates
que vous proposez sont bien sûr les
bienvenus
mais les agriculteurs veulent une réelle
garantie des prix une amélioration de la
contractualisation au sein des filières
afin de la rendre saine et équilibrée
une révision des normes et contraintes
imposées ces dernières années que ne
supportent pas un certain nombre de nos
partenaires européens et qui freine la
compétitivité de nos exploitations
françaises
monsieur le ministre seuls des solutions
pérennes permettront à nos agriculteurs
à nos éleveurs de vivre de leur métier
de nourrir nos concitoyens en produits
étiquetés français est de maintenir la
vitalité dans le territoires ruraux et
la parole est un monsieur stéphane le
foll mais les agriculteurs de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt se
présente ce débuté chose
le constat est le fait qu'ils aient eu
des alertes je les ai tout entendu et
depuis
d'un an sur cette question on a
travaillé par rapport et je le dis une
situation qu'a commencé avec la filière
porcine qui avait été aussi identifié
sur la filière bovine et qui sur la
question du lait est venu je le dis de
manière très claire d'un effondrement du
prix à l'échelle mondiale de la poudre
et du beurre et qui s'ajoute à la
difficulté que nous avions sur les deux
autres filières vous évoquez à partir de
là les mesures qui ont été mises en
place et vous avez en particulier parler
de la contractualisation
bien sûr qu'il faut résoudre le problème
des prix et c'est tout l'enjeu de la
négociation qu'on a engagés pour essayer
de remonter des prix je le dis quand
même ça sera assez rare dans l'histoire
que la un ministre c'est un teg et
sincère dans des négociations
commerciales pour faire remonter des
prix alors qu'ils étaient en train de
continuer de baisser quand on a fait ce
que nous avons fait on redresse non
seulement une baisse des prix mais on
les fait remonter par le consensus par
le travail collectif
vous parlez de la contractualisation en
particulier la viande bovine est ce qu
elle existe elle n'existe pas vous me
posez la question de savoir s'il ya une
confiance entre les différents
opérateurs et producteurs aujourd'hui ça
n'existe pas c'est bien le sujet qui
nous est posée comment on fait pour
remettre de la confiance du dialogue de
l'écouté parce que on peut rester les
uns et les autres chacun campé dans ses
positions et renvoyer la responsabilité
non notre responsabilité
ma responsabilité c'est d'assumer et
d'assurer cette confiance d'assurer et
d'assumer la volonté que chacun doit
avoir de dialoguer on construira
l'avenir avec les mesures bien sûr mais
aussi par la confiance et le dialogue